die klimaaktivisten wie sie sich selbst
nennen haben wieder zugeschlagen
klimakaoten sagen die die zunehmend
genervt davon sind darf der umweltzweck
die Mittel heiligen Nötigung zum
Beispiel auch darum geht es
das dritte Mal in nur einer Woche drei
Aktionen der klimakaoten in nur drei
Tagen der aktuelle Vorfall rote Beete
Saft vor dem Verkehrsministerium Montag
stürmen Demonstranten das
Bundesministerium für Finanzen
[Musik]
diesen Moment besetzen etwa 30
Aktivisten das Finanzministerium sie
wollen auf die missliche
Schuldensituation des globalen Südens
aufmerksam machen Deutschland spielt
dabei eine wichtige Rolle
die Besetzer schaffen es bis ins
Vorzimmer von Minister Christian Lindner
geben sich als Besuchergruppe aus
bereits am Sonntag Kapern klimakaoten
das Gebäude in dem der deutsche
weltklimagipfeltagt kleben sich am
Eingang fest Gerechtigkeit weltweit kann
wir an die Demonstranten und fordern
jetzt
im Inneren des Gebäudes spricht der
Kanzler als plötzlich Feueralarm
ausgelöst wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der Protest wird schließlich von der
Polizei aufgelöst ob der Alarm
tatsächlich durch die Besetzer kam
bleibt ungeklärt
[Musik]
von klimakaoten vor einer Woche
nachweislich ausgelöst wurde der
Feueralarm im Bundestag
[Musik]
deshalb werde ich gleich im
Bundestag Feierabend
[Musik]
über 40 Feuerwehrleute Rücken an um auf
den falschen Alarm zu reagieren wir
brauchen jetzt
einen 100 und das 9 € Ticket ich frage
mich mittlerweile sogar ob die Regierung
die Situation noch im Griff hat
Besetzungen Straßenblockaden Fehlalarme
die Aktionen und Aktivitäten der
klimakaoten häufen sich ziviler
Ungehorsam oder Vandalismus fakt ist
immer mehr Menschen überschreiten die
Grenzen des friedlichen Protestes weil
ihrer Meinung nach nicht genug gegen den
Klimawandel unternommen wird
[Musik]
wir können uns nicht noch mehr Öl und
Gasverbrauch leisten
sorgt euch mehr um ein Gemälde als um
das Wohl unseres Planeten und der
gesamten Menschheit
[Musik]
drei Aktionen in nur drei Tagen dreimal
schlagen die klimakaoten vor politischen
Institutionen zu was erwartet uns an Tag
4 steht die Eskalation der klimaproteste
bevor
[Musik]
und was bedeutet das da sprechen wir
darüber mit Joachim Steinhöfel er ist
Rechtsanwalt und bild-kolumnist und
bekannt für Klartext guten Abend Herr
steinhöfe
welche Strafen haben die Protestler zu
erwarten die wir da gesehen haben
also das Grundproblem ist glaube ich
dass hier Leute aktiv werden die glauben
weil sie für eine gute Sache eintreten
können sie machen was sie wollen das was
wir da teilweise gesehen haben auch
Ministerien zu stürmen erinnert mich
zwar nicht an den sechsten januar in den
USA das hat eine völlig andere Dimension
und es erinnert mich auch nicht
unbedingt an den Pass gelungenen Sturm
des Reichs des Reichstages dass ich mich
fast ganz peinlich historisch
versprochen das Reichstags der war in
der Demo stattgefunden hat aber es zeigt
doch einem bis Achtung demokratischer
Institutionen und einen Willen Recht und
Gesetz zu brechen der in einem
Demokratie fehl am Platz ist die
Straftaten die da begangen werden können
wir aus den Videos natürlich nur
teilweise sehen das sind sicher
Sachbeschädigung Hausfriedensbruch und
vielleicht kommt noch das eine oder
andere dazu
Politiker verlangen dann immer es solle
mit der ganzen Härte des Gesetzes
geahndet werden etwas das ist gar nicht
gibt denn es gibt immer nur eine Tat
angemessene Strafe und solange diese
Sachen nicht geahndet werden wird dass
ich ja weitergehen sind diese Strafen
schöne Lasche als beispielsweise bei
Nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten
ja das ist immer das kann man so
pauschal überhaupt nicht beantworten ich
das hängt immer davon ab was ist konkret
geschehen hat man den Baum gefällt auf
Nachbars Grundstück ja oder nein aber
wenn ich hier gerade diese Bilder sehe
das van gogh-gemälde in London vor dem
ich selber gestanden habe und die
Ausstellung habe ich selber gesehen die
ist da schon lange die ein tief
beeindruckt das ist auch die Schöpfung
das ist auch das Erbe der Menschheit und
das gegen das hier in einer dümmlichen
und arroganten Art und Weise agiert wird
die völlig indiskutabel ist da müsste
man in der Tat Schadensersatz verlangen
auch gegen die Täter selbst und das
nicht unter dem Oberbegriff subsumieren
die wollen ja nur das Gute und deswegen
lassen wir es laufen der Weg zur Hölle
ist gepflastert mit den Vorsätzen mit
guten Vorsätzen heißt es ja und genau
das ist hier richtig nur ich glaube sehr
oft wird hier ein Auge zugedrückt zu
Unrecht
danke für die Einordnung Herr Steinhöfel
gerne
[Musik]